all right what is my favorite movie i
always have a hard time with this one
i'm a taurus my favorite movie of all
time of all time unequivocally without
hesitation it would definitely be little
women terms of endearment king kong okay
i'm just gonna go outside the box who
framed roger rabbit
rabbit the last unicorn the perfect
combination of everything i love about
the movies all wrapped up into one it's
weird it's dark and it's allegedly a
family movie
i love the whiz being able to see
representation on screen like that the
entire feel of the movie gave you such
authenticity it still hits citizen game
top gun i remember watching it when i
was eight years old and thinking i want
to be a fighter pilot when i grow up
they saw shank redemption avatar and
that didn't happen but i can still watch
it and pretend my favorite movie is
black widow x-men days of future past i
grew up with the original x-men movie i
was always the edge of my seat i felt
emotionally invested
screamed by wes craven the virgin
suicides changed my life forever it took
over my entire world orange mechanic the
stanley kubrick is a classic and fair to
remember fair to remember i still get
emotional
understand
the good the bad and the ugly sought
with my dad made the film even more
special my favorite movie is ralph
breaks the internet
encanto coda goodwill hunting sharkboy
and lava girl i continue to watch it to
this day over and over again one of the
best films i ever seen eight and a half
by federico felini i grew up in godzilla
and mackerel my favorite film is
parasites
the lord of the rings the peter jackson
my favorite film would have to be star
wars
because of the cool white tape arrivals
and the action frank cappers it's a
wonderful life
of human hearts 1938 bengali
my favorite movie is greece my favorite
part in the movie is the handgun
my favorite movie is chinatown the
extraordinary screenplay by robert town
blows it out of the water and it's got
jack in it the terminal the adjustment
bureau
pursuit of happiness the message if you
have a dream then just go get it and
that just fuels my desire to keep going
my favorite film of all time is malcolm
x because it taught me so much about
black history sabrina is my favorite
movie because it depicts the tale of a
young woman's journey through
self-discovery my favorite movie is
shall we dance my husband and i every
time we watch the movie we dance to the
music when i watch the movie it brings
such a sweet memories it always makes me
smile when people find their happily
ever after every time i've shown this to
someone they have said what did i just
watch or why did you just show that to
me it's the first movie i watched that
made me really fall in love with movies
always give me absolute delight very
deep emotional timeless piece of art
made me wonder what other movies are out
there that i could connect to in that
way the mark of an unforgettable film
it's kind of a miracle
that's what i think the great movies are
they're little miracles
thanks for watching bye
you